it's the desire for the latest model
that drives the mobile phone industry
but after an average of two to three
years use ninety percent of these
handsets won't be formally recycled then
you can open the phone like a book
companies are now being forced to find a
sustainable future for phones Nokia is
encouraging customers to repair and
recycle their devices people in the
industry say giving handsets second and
third lives is crucial in the industry
about 1.5 billion devices come into the
market every single year and this year
over 5 billion devices are going to end
up in landfill or in drawers
and that is a real problem because that
just means we're going to continue to
make more and more devices ultimately
today only 10 to 15 percent of a new
device sales is accompanied by a traded
in device and that's just too low these
80 phones have been weaved into an
abstract art piece demonstrating the
potentials of the circular economy
because by extending the life of all the
smartphones in the world by just one
year we could reduce carbon emissions by
20 million tons that's the equivalent of
taking 4.7 million cars off the road
reducing emissions at source is a more
accepted goal in the industry with a
commitment to reach Net Zero by 2050.
some companies are already on track to
reach 100 renewable energy years before
then others are lagging Behind still
refusing to disclose their carbon
emissions output this ambition Net Zero
ambition was actually ahead of any of
the G7 economies and since then we have
been helping our members on climate
disclosure so there is a global
reporting platform for this called the
CDP and in the last year 67 of our
members reported to the CDP and this
actually covers 80 of the industry
Revenue but the industry believes it can
make an even bigger contribution to
climate action through digitization here
teams are brainstorming a solution so
the challenge of the day is how might we
satisfy the food and water demands of an
urban area in a sustainable way from
Post-its to prototype using Tech to
solve the problem with a tight
self-imposed deadline the sense of
urgency helps Drive momentum similar
urgency for action on climate goals and
sustainability could be encouraged by
mobile customers Charlie Angela Al
Jazeera Barcelona